[Música]
economía en directo américa de france 24
daniela yo ya tengo que hacer mercado
dentro de poco y me va a dar más miedo
ni lo haga no porque porque es que la
infección en este país la más alta en
dos décadas no en colombia sí señor raúl
y si me permite antes de voy a dar un
dato que salió de última hora como se le
para seguir más tres ámbitos para seguir
martirizando se mire la el desempleo en
eeuu que estábamos esperando lo 3,6 por
ciento en abril es la misma fecha la
misma cifra que en marzo y es el menor
nivel desde que inició la pandemia antes
de la pandemia desempleo en eeuu era
como del 3,5 por ciento aproximadamente
con la pandemia subió se dispara hasta
el 14,7 por ciento en abril de 2020 y
vuelve otra vez a retomar la buena senda
ahora si colombia mire los precios al
consumidor en el país subieron 9 2% en
abril pasado frente al mismo mes de 2001
está la cifra más alta desde julio del
2000 y lo que más subió fueron los
alimentos y las prendas de vestir pero
las alzas históricas son un fenómeno que
no solamente es viviendo en colombia
sino también en todo el continente y en
gran parte del mundo debido entre otros
a la guerra en ucrania y a los rezagos
económicos que heredó la pandemia además
de colombia eeuu lucha con su inflación
más alta en 40 años méxico y argentina
lo hacen contra el mayor nivel de
precios en 20 años brasil no había visto
tal repunte en 18 años chileno lo hacía
desde 2004 y es por eso que siguen
subiendo las tasas de interés en los
bancos centrales claro raúl y como lo
hemos dicho varias veces pues el hecho
de frenar la inflación sin parar de
golpe el crecimiento es justamente el
trabajo complicado que enfrentan los
bancos centrales del mundo a nivel
regional ya hablamos esta semana de que
colombia estados unidos y brasil
elevaron sus tipos de intervención ahora
chile se suma también el jueves a esta
lista subió sus tasas en más de un punto
hasta el 8 25 por ciento y esto es lo
que va a implicar es un mayor costo del
endeudamiento para los hogares en este
país cambiamos ahora información danny
porque la unión europea sigue debatiendo
un posible embargo
rusia y no se ponen de acuerdo todavía
no señor llevan toda la semana
discutiendo lo pero no hay consenso en
cuanto a la imposición de un sexto
paquete de sanciones contra el kremlin
porque hay países como hungría
eslovaquia y república checa- reacios a
un embargo petrolero esto por su gran
dependencia y a pesar de que otros
países como alemania que también es
bastante dependiente ya cambiaron de
posición
la comisión europea continúa este
viernes intentando convencerlos de que
voten a favor de este veto texto con una
exportación de petróleo y derivados del
petróleo como el gasóleo para
calefacción es una de las principales
fuentes de ingresos del kremlin y es
precisamente esta fuente de ingresos la
que queremos agotar en los próximos
meses para que no sea posible que putin
siga financiando su guerra al mismo
tiempo protegemos nuestra economía lo
más posible si añadimos entonces a
úrsula von der layen la presidenta de la
comisión europea hablando al respecto
han y seguimos en europa porque en
españa la más reciente reforma laboral
parece estar dando buenos resultados no
pues sí señor a comienzos de este año el
parlamento de este país aprobó una
reforma que entre otros puntos modificó
la contratación temporal que es uno de
los principales problemas del mercado
laboral español también recuperó los
convenios colectivos y estableció un
modelo que un nuevo modelo de erte que
es una medida que les permite a las
empresas suspender y despedir a personas
con trabajos temporales al hacer un
balance cuatro meses después el
ministerio de trabajo aseguró que la
proporción entre contratos indefinidos y
temporales ha venido cambiando miremos
en diciembre por cada empleado
contratado indefinidamente había nueve
temporales y en abril ya la proporción
era casi igual en ambos tipos de
contrato y es que en españa hay 20
millones de afiliados al sistema de
seguridad social y hay unos 3 millones
de desempleados la cifra más baja desde
2008 bueno danny buena noticia esperemos
que así se mantenga y que se iguale o
sino que los empleos indefinidos también
suban o sí señor dan indicadores los
mercados cierran a la baja a medida que
incrementan los temores de que el
aumento de las tasas de interés frene el
crecimiento económico en asia pacifico
hubo caídas mientras que en londres
fráncfort y parís siguen baja después de
que estados unidos revelará esta tasa de
desempleo que le acabo de contar y que
nos trae como cifra el día hoy 600 euros
o raúl es es el tope de un subsidio al
servicio de energía que está ofreciendo
el gobierno griego a los ciudadanos esto
es un programa de apoyo que busca
reembolsar hasta el 60 por ciento de
todos los recargos de electricidad que
los consumidores hayan pagado desde
diciembre hasta mayo y esta sala fija a
dónde vamos
guatemala no a parís
seguidas no me pida tanto danny gracias
por toda la información es vamos a la
semana que viene vamos a parís